hi good afternoon thanks for coming I'm
going to tell you a story today about
there
ship between two programming languages
Alda is a text-based music composition
language and closure as you may know is
a functional programming oriented Lisp
that runs on the JVM but first some
introductions are in order hi I'm Dave I
studied music composition and bassoon
performance and then there was a six
year period of my life where I kind of
fell into a government job that had
nothing to do with music or programming
but I was dabbling and programming at
the time and at some point I got the
crazy idea to combine my interests of
music and programming and out of that
emerged alda which I will talk about in
a couple slides since 2014 I've been
working as a software engineer at add
zurk which has been greatly rewarding I
would like to talk a little bit more
about that because we're hiring we have
a booth upstairs please come say hi if
you're about to say is interesting to
you we're a rolled world-class platform
for decision making it's scale you can
use our ad-serving api's to build your
own fully custom ad-serving platform in
a matter of weeks we get to do a lot of
closure there which I really enjoy
closure is my favorite programming
language among other things and it's a
smallish company or a fully remote team
of about 30 people roughly 10 engineers
and we're looking to grow so come find
me on slack or after the talk or come
talk to us upstairs so here's the
elevator pitch for Alda Alda is a text
format for expressing a music
composition imagine if you could write
music by writing and editing text in a
text file in your editor of choice and
imagine if you had a command-line client
that you could use to interpret and
perform your score and then as a bonus
imagine if that were integrated into
your text editor of choice so that you
could highlight some text and press a
couple of keys and hear what your the
music that you're writing played back to
you this is a sort of tight feedback
loop that we love as programmers and
that's the sort of experience that I
wanted to bring to music composition as
a bit of context this is the sort of
environment that I was composing music
and
all through college and for a little
while afterwards
this is Sibelius which is an industry
standard for music composition many
professional composers use Sibelius and
other programs like it there's another
one called finale these are highly
visual mouse oriented like environments
for composing music you you know there
are keyboard shortcuts that if you spend
enough time with the software you can
learn them but by and large you are
dragging things around on the screen
trying to pinpoint just the right line
or space on the staff for the note that
you want to set down or hunting through
menus and panels to try to find the
symbol that you'd like to place on your
score and this works fine for me at the
time I didn't know too much about
programming or software development and
I didn't realize that there was a
problem there until I got more into
software development and discovered the
efficiency of working at the
command-line this is the sort of
environment that I find cumbersome
because you want to express an idea that
you have in your head maybe you've you
have your guitar out or you're at a
piano or you're playing around with your
whatever instrument you that you that
you play that you're working with to
help you compose music and you just want
to notate that sometimes it takes quite
a long time to notate the idea that you
have in your head because it's quite
complex so there's this trap that you
end up falling into and you spend a lot
of time with software like this my
composition professor warned me against
this which is that if you if you lean
too heavily on this on this sort of
software which you can you can use to
play back what you've what you've
written there's a play button or you can
press the spacebar and hear what you've
written right directly afterwards you
kind of end up writing more music that's
more simplistic and repetitive because
it's it can be so difficult sometimes to
notate the idea you have that you'll
settle for something that's sort of half
formed and maybe it sounds ok to you so
copy/paste it a bunch of times so this
is really creatively limiting so the
idea that I've been exploring is a
terminal user interface for music
composition by contrast this is keyboard
oriented I'm able to maintain focus
because I'm not looking through menus
they're trying to visually layout my
score rather I have an idea in my
had and I'd kind of know the notes that
I want to write and I'll write them
maybe I've gotten one of the notes
slightly wrong I forgotten an accidental
or something but I can highlight what I
want to play and press a couple of
keystrokes I'll hear that slightly wrong
and I can correct it so I find this sort
of workflow very efficient and very
liberating before I go much further I'd
like to give you just a quick demo of
Alda and I have a note for myself here
that time is of the essence I can't
spend a whole lot of time on this demo I
have given a couple of talks in the past
where I've gone into more detail and
given a sort of gentle introduction to
Alda and its various features and how to
use them to get up and running and start
writing scores so I'd encourage you to
check those out if what I'm showing you
here is intriguing to you but I'm not
going to give you the gentle
introduction here I'm just going to
throw you in the deep end this is a
transcription of an excerpt of string
quartet by Debussy and before I say
anything about it I'm just going to play
it
[Music]
so I'll give you a couple brief mentions
of some syntax here at a high level the
score is the score consists of four
instrument parts there are two violins
which I've nicknamed violin one and
violin - there's a viola part and
there's a cello part and they're playing
music concurrently and we begin each
part by specifying what octave we are in
cellos in octave - viola is an octave 3
violin - is also in octave 3 file and
one is knocked at 4
a note is simply a letter followed by
optionally followed by a note length
like a quarter note this is a G quarter
note and this is an F quarter note tied
to an eighth note and we have various
other things that I don't have time to
go into you right now - is and pluses or
flats and sharps and you may also notice
that there's some parenthetical
expressions sort of littered at littered
throughout the score and if you're a
closure programmer perhaps this one
looks a little bit interesting to you
maybe it looks a little familiar this is
actually a closure a snippet of closure
code now close your expression the alter
runtime is written in closure and we
expose evaluation semantics so that you
can it gives you a sort of an in-line
Lisp scripting layer if you will here's
a simpler example so Alda is basically
two languages in one there's this markup
style that I've talked real briefly
about where you have syntactic elements
that represent things directly like
we're saying here this is a piano part
and it's knocked at four and we have
these four notes in a chord
but you can also express anything you
could express in markup with closure
code there's a DSL that's built into the
ear evaluation context that gives you
useful functions like chord and note and
pitch so why is this useful well we have
the full power of closure at our
disposal because we're literally just
evaluating code within a context and
anybody who spent some time with closure
can tell you that closure has a
wonderful standard library consisting of
many useful functions out of the box I'm
still discovering new closure functions
everyday that I didn't know existed in
the the closure core namespace and there
are a number of useful functions for
dealing with sequences which translates
nicely into managing sequences of notes
so I can do things like define a
function that will return n random notes
and then I can say give me four random
notes and then repeat this phrase and
this this is the closure syntax
intermingled with the mark-up syntax
this is fun because every time you
evaluate it you get different notes
and from there you can continue to
continue to experiment and play with the
closure programming language and see
what you can do with these sequences of
notes here's an example where if you use
closures iterate and rest functions
together in this example we have a
sequence of 16 random notes and then
we're going to iterate the rest function
over that so next we have a sequence of
just the last 15 notes and then we'll
have a sequence of the last 14 notes and
these all get spliced together so you
get this repeating pattern that gets
shorter every time you hear it that
concludes that demo Thanks so the main
thing that I want to drive home about
this demo is that closure is sort of a
you know it's sort of a subset of all
des it's sort of like cohabitating
within the alder language as part of the
language which is something that will
change over time so keep that in the
back of your mind at this point I would
like to talk about architecture I'll
talk about how I've gone through several
different phases of how I've put
together the pieces and all des and
we'll see how closure plays a role in
each of those around 2013 when I first
implemented all jellal des enclosure it
was just a single closure program and
that was the quickest way that I could
get to you something that I could play
around with so you use this command line
client to to say hey play play these
three notes on the piano and then this
closure program will parse this into the
code it'll build up a score object in
memory is the data structure and it will
perform that data structure as music so
this got me up up and running but there
are a couple of problems for one thing
closure is notorious for having a long
start up time which makes it unsuitable
for writing command line applications if
you care about how
fast that that program can run sometimes
it's on the order of several seconds so
you'll issue a command and then a few
seconds later the program abroad and
that was fine for at first but the more
I played with it the more I wanted just
even more immediate feedback I wanted to
you know within milliseconds I wanted to
hear the music that I was writing
another problem that I discovered as I
was playing around with this initial
prototype is that this workflow was
synchronous
I would play a score and then I would
not regain control of my terminal until
the score was finished playing so I
began to feel like I wanted to play a
score and then I would kind of pick
something out my ear would hear
something that didn't sound quite right
or I wanted to tweak it and so I
immediately want to hit that up arrow
and and edit that command so I started
thinking about a more a synchronous
interface so those problems in forms
phase two and this was also kind of
early on in my career as a software
developer so I wasn't really quite aware
about inter process communication
mechanisms so I went with the only thing
that I knew how to build which is an
HTTP server and I pulled out just the
part that talks to the HTTP server so we
have this client that's now written in
Java which is great because it starts up
quickly it's cross-platform so I can
easily create in alda for for Linux and
Mac OS users and Aldo XE for Windows
users with the closure part bundled in
and so the workflow is that you you run
all des up to start your server and that
spawns a new process in the background
that's running this closure server and
that server is just going to sit there
and wait for input from you and so then
you'll say hey all that play these three
notes on a piano and you'll hear the
result immediately the server is doing
all of the work so this solved the
problem for me of this closure startup
time where I wanted to hear the result
immediately and it solved the issue of
playback being synchronous but there's a
new problem someone pointed out to me
that hey HTTP is a little bit overkill
if all you want to do is inter process
communication it turns out that there's
all this overhead that comes with HTTP
you have to parse headers
there's there's all these subtleties of
the format and if you're picking up an
HTTP server library off the shelf
chances are it's it's starting a pool of
threads that are going to handle these
requests maybe all you need is one
thread so a contributor to all the early
on pointed out that there are other ways
to do this and so this led to the phase
3 there's also another problem which I'm
going to skim over right now because I
did not solve it in phase 3 so phase 3
this is actually exactly the same
architecture there's still just a server
process in the background and a Java
client that talks to the server but I
replaced the communication with zero and
Q what is zero and Q it is a message
protocol for distributed messaging it's
quite handy there are a variety of
libraries for 0 mq in a bunch of
different languages so you can use it to
talk back and forth between programs
that are written in different languages
it's a very simple protocol essentially
it's just byte arrays with with frames
and it uses the same abstractions for if
you're talking between multiple threads
in a single process or if you're talking
between multiple processes on a single
machine or if you're communicating
between multiple nodes on the server you
have the same abstractions that you can
work with and I like to think of zero
and Q as being sort of like working with
sockets directly except that it's really
difficult to do that so 0 and Q does a
lot of kind of housekeeping for you
behind the scenes there are various
patterns that you can achieve by
plumbing together different types of
sockets so here's a very simple example
of a program you might write using 0 and
Q and the neat thing here is that the
client and the server here could be
threads in a single program or they
could be multiple programs being run
across the world from each other it
doesn't matter
each program or where each thread
creates an instance of a 0 mq socket
that has a particular type so the client
has a request socket and the server has
a response socket and all the tapping
here is that the client is using that
socket to send an array of bytes to the
server
and the server has the knowledge through
the through the 0 mq library it has a
sort of implicit knowledge of where that
message came from and so it just is
listening for messages and responding to
them and a byte array goes back to the
client it's simple
so this solved the issue of HTTP being
overkill for IPC and I still had this
problem that I glossed over before which
is that I was starting to notice that if
I played a score too close together if I
was maybe trying to iterate on something
I was writing and I played something
back-to-back too quickly or Fri play two
scores at the same time for some crazy
reason the audio would glitch out and go
crazy the reason for that is that I'm
using the the Java there's actually a
built-in synthesizer a MIDI synthesizer
in the JVM and it just so happens that
if you have multiple instances of that
synthesizer in a single process they
don't play nicely together
I suppose that they're both trying to
get too greedy with resources so I was
able to use 0 mq to make things a little
bit more complicated but achieve having
playback happening on multiple processes
so you notice things are starting to get
a little more complex in the
architecture diagram here so now we have
these worker processes that are just the
sort of the business logic pulled out of
the server these worker processes are
parsing code evaluating that code and
performing your score for you so now the
server has a different role now it's job
is to spawn and supervise these worker
processes and its job is to receive
requests from a client and find a worker
that's available and hand that request
to the worker and then when the worker
is done it will hand the request back to
the client so this is kind of nice
because the client doesn't really need
to worry about the worker processes all
it cares about is where the server is
how it can talk to the server it's
running on a particular port and it
receives a message it receives a
response back to the request so 3
visitor problems but first let's look at
the 0 mq architecture diagram so this is
instead of requesting and response
sockets the semantics are slightly
different so we
have a combination of socket types
called dealer and router and basically
the idea is that you have you have
parties on either side of the of the
transaction here of the you think of
this is a sort of business transaction
so your dealers are the client and the
worker processes and the server is just
functioning as a go-between or a broker
so a message comes in from the client
the server finds an available worker and
routes the request to the worker the
worker sends a response back to the
server and the server will route that
request back to the client
I was surprised how easy it was to build
something like this with zero MQ so
let's revisit our problems this fixed
the issue of the audio glitching which
is great but there's sort of a side
effect that emerged with this which is
that the this architecture is getting a
bit complex at this point I started
running into issues some people reported
issues where they would start the server
and the server would say okay I'm up now
I'm starting the worker processes and
then it would just hang there forever
we're like what's what's going on there
apparently the server was having issues
starting background processes of its own
perhaps certain operating systems like
maybe Windows operating systems certain
versions of Windows don't let background
processes start their own background
processes and this is very difficult for
me to debug without having somebody's
computer sitting in front of me so I
started whining to simplify things a
little bit another issue is that this
workflow since phase 2 when I introduced
the server to begin with the user now
needs to worry about having a server up
and running this doesn't work like it
does in a lot of other you know a lot of
other compilers or interpreters like if
you fire up Ruby you're not needing to
start a Ruby server to get work done so
I kinda wanted to solve that problem
another issue is that there's a finite
number of workers usually there's two by
default because that's often as many as
you need but even if you have more
there's still this problem where if
you're doing work too quickly and been
firing off too many requests if all the
workers are busy then there's no worker
available to take your request and the
server just tells you try again later
all the workers are busy so it's not a
great user experience so with all these
things in mind
started to put together a wish list of
the way I wanted all that to work in the
next major version I wanted to move most
of the functionality into the client I
wanted to do away with this idea of
having background processes that the end
user has to care about and just make it
a nicer experience but at the same time
I did want to have a background thread
or process for for playing your scores
because I wanted to maintain that
asynchronous workflow where you can say
play something and then immediately
regain control of your terminal so I
wanted to have I started thinking
thinking about having a process that
does nothing except for just the
playback bit because I was moving most
of the functionality into the client I
would have to address that initial
problem that I ran into in phase one
which is that the closure runtime takes
a while to bootstrap so I started
thinking about maybe there's a way that
I can generate native executables or
just get things running faster closer to
the metal there's also another thing
that I wanted to add in which is
completely orthogonal to everything I've
mentioned so far so bear with me but I
want to support live coding I want you
to be able to play a score and maybe
you're maybe the score is that you want
to play a pattern forever and then while
that pattern is playing I want you to be
able to come back and say okay that
score you're playing change it a little
bit let's maybe change the notes and
you'll hear that update the next time
the pattern loops through so these are
all things that I was thinking about and
here's the fitly phase five architecture
that I came up with so this is a lot
simpler less to worry about it's almost
like the phase one architecture and that
you just have a client and you're saying
hey do this and the alda client will do
most of the work of parsing this the
parsing your code building up a score
object in memory when it comes to
playback the client has transparently
started a process in the background to
use for playback and the client will
then communicate with that player
process by sending OSC messages so I
decided to change the transport from 0
mq to OSC which is call it's a open
sound control OSC is the de facto
standard for communication between
computers and synthesizers and various
other music software and multimedia
devices
you can use it to control lights a lot
of cool applications for OSC the
transport is UDP which is great because
it's low latency it's ideally suited for
live audio and video applications so the
more I thought about it the more I
thought that OSU would be a good fit for
Alta and it's a it's very easy to get up
and running with OSC there are libraries
for a bunch of different languages the
message structure is simple it's
open-ended you basically have two parts
there's the address which can have
patterns in it so the the OSC listener
can listen for these messages and
extract the data it needs from the
address part so in this case we're
sending a message that is supposed to
play a MIDI note on track one and then
the rest of the message is parameters
and in this case these are all numbers
but there are a variety of different
types of parameters that are supported
by most OSC libraries like strings
characters MIDI messages blobs of binary
data and you can even define your own
custom data types which is very useful
so I'm going to go back to this phase 5
diagram and you may have noticed
something subtle that I've left out
which is that I left out any programming
language logos and the reason for that
is that I was sort of saving a shocking
revelation for this slide you may be
surprised to hear that I've switched out
the implementation from closure to go
and Kotlin yeah gasp this this will
particularly come as a shock to you if
you know how much I love closure you
know what am I doing here
but the reason for that is really that
you know for the reasons I listed in the
previous slide I wanted to create native
executables so I can get really close to
the medal with performance
I wanted the client to do all of the
work and it's also important to me to
generate executables that are you can
just whatever your operating system is
whatever your architecture is you can
just download the release from github
put it somewhere on your path and it
will work and out of the options I tried
which included go and rust and crystal
go is the only one where I could easily
do that with the with the executables
being totally devoid of dynamic link
so no native libraries required and it
was interesting coming to go from
closure because go is a bit limiting for
my for my perspective as a closure
programmer it was a bit of a culture
shock coming into it but the more I
worked with go the more I sort of
started if you view the limitations as
an asset it's actually kind of nice
being limited sometime it's because it
makes your code easy to read it's very
easy to reason about something if
there's only one way you can do it right
so this is where closure fits into the
picture now it's very important to me
that I'd be able to continue to write
algorithmic music in closure and I had
to find a way to do that and I actually
found that this is a better place in the
diagram for closure to fit because now I
have complete control of a closure
process maybe I can write a closure
program that that drives Alda and does
exactly what I want to do with it so I
was able to get this running it's good
to get this workflow working by writing
this library for closure called Alda clj
it is a closure library for live coding
music with Alda and what it's doing is
really pretty simple you you have the
same sort of musical DSL that I showed
you earlier in the previous demo where
you have functions like note and chord
and under the hood all the clj is
generating a string of Alda that's valid
all the syntax that gets sent to the
Alda command-line client so I'm going to
demo that for you now
okay so the library is really one
namespace albacore that has all the
useful functions in it and one of the
functions that you get is all des this
basically just lets you shell out to the
command-line client so you can do things
like get the version or check the status
of the worker processes and as you can
see you have the same DSL for working
with your musical score and when you
when you call this function
it not only sends the Elda code to the
command-line client it will also return
the string of code so you can kind of
see what you're doing and you know just
I have a closure repple running in the
background that I'm connected to you so
I'm in control of this process so of
course it stands to reason I have the
closure standard library available to me
so I can continue to do interesting
things with sequences so you're sort of
a basic example where I have notes from
c d e f and g and then i'm just
injecting rests in between them you can
see this in the the alda code c rest
dear st rest and of course i can
leverage randomness which is always fun
[Music]
I always think it's fun to generate
random sequences of notes with random
rhythms and random pitches because when
I listened back to that I kind of my ear
picks up on little things that sound
interesting to me and then I can go to a
piano or pick up my guitar and try to
figure out what the notes are and
compose something interesting with it so
I've used this to create pieces of
algorithmic music here's one where I've
defined a function that returns a random
note that has a random pitch in a random
duration or it might choose to rest for
a certain amount of time and then I just
say you know I've got three I've got
these three parts an electric piano a
timpani and a Celeste and I just want
each of those to invoke this function 50
times to figure out what what part it's
going to play
[Music]
so some interesting sounds emerged from
that the last thing I'm going to show
you is a piece that I wrote specifically
for this conference and I wanted to
demonstrate that you can use external
closure libraries when you're using the
Aldous elj library so in this case I'm
pulling in an HTTP client and a JSON
library and I'm what I'm doing is I'm
pulling weather data from the National
Weather Service API let's try to
memorize these these instruments so New
York is percussion LA is an upright bass
st. Louis is a tenor sax and Durham
where I'm from is a vibraphone maybe
I'll show that while I'm playing the
score so we can keep it in our heads so
I'm hitting the API I'm getting when
what you get back is a list of 15 data
points for the next 15 our windows in a
particular city or at a particular set
of coordinates and so you know this is
most of the code I'm just getting I'm
fetching that forecast I'm reading it
reading the JSON grabbing the forecast
data out of it and that's that's about
it and then once I have that data in
hand I am doing this so I'm using
various data very bits of information
from these forecasting periods the
temperature I'm using verbatim as the
MIDI note number so MIDI note numbers go
from 0 to 127 so these are sort of in
the upper mid-range but I'm also
adjusting the octave so that for example
the upright bass sounds lower the wind
direction affects the panning so
assuming that stereo works in here you
might hear the the instruments moving
from left to right or vice versa
depending on which direction the wind is
blowing and the wind speed affects how
fast the notes are coming at you as well
as how loud they're coming at you so if
you hear notes getting louder and faster
that means that the wind is picking up
in that City
so without further ado hopefully this
will work
[Music]
seems like New York is usually pretty
windy
[Music]
luis that the tenor sax sounds kind of
high-pitched it's because it's been hot
lately
as we're all aware
[Music]
so anyway you get the idea that's all
I've got
looks like I've gotta bait about eight
minutes left thank you
so I have some time left for questions
yes yeah the question was have you
considered using this on the data from
the recent hurricane yes a hurricane
came through North Carolina where I'm
from and it sounded about like you would
expect a lot a lot of fast notes coming
at you yes in the back in phase five so
I'm still using I'll put that diagram
back up so I'm using Kotlin on the
players side so this is still a JVM
process yes the question is is the
similarity between all the syntax and
lily pond syntax accidental absolutely
not
I definitely stole a bunch of ideas from
lily pond another big inspiration for
the syntax was music macro language or
FML which is you might know this if you
had a flip phone and you programmed
ringtones into its kind of similar
syntax to that yes
I'm have that sort of working on a
branch the the current release is still
the phase for architecture actually yes
yeah that's a good question the question
was in phase 5 since closure has now
been pulled out and is not a part of the
player process or the client how do I
maintain that that closure syntax and
the fact is I had to make a breaking
change there there was actually still a
lisp in all dubby - which is implemented
didn't go and it's a it's sort of I
think of it as like a dumb Lisp like you
can't really do much with it it doesn't
have macros it's basically right now
it's just a way to invoke functions and
everything is built-in but in the future
I could see that potentially expanding
and sort of bringing that that scripting
layer back in that's a fun thing to play
with yes in the back
yeah the question is have I thought
about integrating the client with with
different backends like supercollider
and that would definitely be a fun thing
to play with that's actually when the
motivations of pulling out just the
plate just a playback bit by itself
because this Kotlin program it took me
you know maybe a couple weeks to write
it was pretty simple because all the
logic is happening in the client so you
know the interface here is OSC messages
so you know in the future I might play
around with alternate backends maybe
like a Web Audio API back-end would be
fun if you'd open up a browser and use
that to play music yes
yeah so the question is is there a way
or have I thought about ways to write
your music in Alda and then export sheet
music and yes there is a way it's it's
not totally great right now but there's
an export mechanism which will what it
actually does is it so there's a there's
an instance of a synthesizer and a
sequencer inside of the Alda runtime and
as you're as you're playing your music
it's actually loading up the sequencer
with with music with MIDI data and so
we're able to export that as a MIDI file
and then from there a lot of graphical
sheet music notation programs can import
MIDI files so you get kind of a rough
estimation of what the sheet music would
look like it's not perfect because it
can't always infer what you meant you
know where you want the bar lines to
fall or you know what if you don't use a
sharp or a flat to represent the same
note so there's still some tweaks to be
made but we're we've got the beginnings
of that any other questions yes
is all the v-2 available to use right
now kind of I'm doing it sort of in the
open there's a v2 branch of the all
delaying slash all the github repo and
hopefully the readme is in a somewhat
decent shape that you could play around
with it if you wanted to but it's not
it's not readily available to download
exactly any other questions well thanks
so much for listening
[Applause]